pero nada en méxico giovanni lópez no
portaba cubrebocas esta brasileña
afrodescendiente no respetaba la
cuarentena tienen en común ser víctimas
de abusos policiales las medidas
extraordinarias contra la propagación
del cob y 19 han dado más poder a los
policías y militares en varios países de
américa latina y hoy las protestas
contra la brutalidad policial se
multiplican en la región las más
recientes en colombia donde el
descontento está y otras y realizarse un
vídeo que muestra la detención de un
hombre que había violado las
restricciones contra la pandemia que aún
permanecen y que luego murió con nueve
fracturas en el cráneo en las protestas
fallecieron 13 personas la mayoría a
tiros a los indiscriminados de fuego no
se lo puede considerar abuso policial
eso es un atentado directo
a ciudadanos y verdes a civiles en su
inmensa mayoría en la misma semana
policías armados realizaron una huelga
en argentina que terminó con una subida
de salarios
argumentaban que la pandemia había
disminuido sus ingresos mientras que su
trabajo se había multiplicado por la
cuarentena en argentina son 530 los
casos de violencia institucional y 92
muertes a manos de las fuerzas de
seguridad sólo durante el curso de la
cuarentena activistas llaman también la
atención sobre la situación de brasil
que en tiempos de pandemia se ha
agravado sólo entre marzo y abril 290
personas murieron en intervenciones
policiales aunque parte de la población
estaba confinada en casa en un país
donde además el ministerio de salud está
en poder de un general del ejército y en
el que durante el mandato de jair
bolsonaro el número de militares y
policías electos se ha cuadruplicado